you are watching ColdFusion TV hi
welcome to another ColdFusion video to
go go here if you ask people what they
think the very first all touchscreen
smartphone was most people would
probably say the original iPhone or if
they knew a bit more about technology
history they might say the LG Prada but
it is by no means either of these phones
to find the answer we have to look even
before the 2000s the story starts in
1971 with fyodor parish giver costs he
was the very first person on earth to
envision devices that combine telephone
communication capabilities and computing
not only that but he was the very first
to introduce the concepts of
intelligence data processing and visual
display screens into telephones Theodore
issued over 20 patents and created a
special transmitter and receiver that
was used within his work at the Boeing
Company although Theodore was a
visionary his inventions never really
found its way outside of Boeing so as a
result they went largely unrecognized
over a decade later in 1984 Motorola
shocked the world with the first ever
mobile phone the DynaTAC 8000x it was a
bulky inefficient thing taking ten hours
to charge for a measly 30 minutes of
talk time but it was the seed of what is
oh so familiar today however it was by
no means smart so we gotta ask the
question when did the smart actually get
into the phone to find out we've got to
continue our story and fast forward into
1992 this was a time when primitive PDAs
or personal digital assistants we're
starting to become hot possessions for
some fun context let's take a quick look
at AT&T s vision of the future through
PDAs or as they called them personal
communicators there's a fax machine
there's the phone there's a voicemail
there's the email the electronic mail
system all of that's all fragment and
it's not all in one place so if it were
all in one place it would be crazy you
are a design a system that works for me
get something that will climb up that
ladder with me
I need something that's gonna work here
I want to be able to take the things I
have at home on the road with me if I
had one in my car it would be even
better my dream system would integrate
voice mail email fax and it would have
one maybe two buttons this is incredible
everything I need to do my job
everything that's on my desk it's right
here in one packet now these are the
kinds of faxes I like to get no my
daughters quite the artist she's really
good to have this kind of information go
where I go and to have it come up on
screen
this is great now this is really
communicating so when can I get one okay
so hold your laughter back then that
kind of stuff was revolutionary also
around this time it's important to note
that laptops themselves were only just
barely becoming feasible while other
companies were experimenting and looking
to find the right combination of
communication capabilities IBM already
had a prototype in this year at a Comdex
computer industry trade show history was
very quietly made IBM showed off a small
prototype phone that they had been
developing it included PDA features and
a large touchscreen in 1994 the phone
was refined further and put onto the
market with the name the Simon Personal
Communicator and you guessed it this was
the very first smartphone interestingly
enough even though the phone was
developed by IBM was actually
manufactured by Mitsubishi electronics
so what could this phone actually do
well in addition to its ability to make
and receive phone calls Simon was able
to send and receive faxes emails and
included several other apps like an
address book calendar appointment
scheduler calculator world time clock
and a notepad through its touch screen
display and stylus it was so advanced
that people didn't even know what they
were really looking at sales of the IBM
Simon was short-lived between August
16th 1994 and was discontinued less than
a year later in February of 1995
it sold 50,000 units for those of you
interested in a few technical fun bits
let's check out some specs of the phone
it had one megabyte of RAM and flash
storage and a 16 megahertz processor
which was actually x86 compatible for
those of you wondering x86 is the chip
architecture used in Windows PCs ok so
how is 16 megahertz when compared to
computers of the day well for comparison
the pcs of the day were around 20 to 100
megahertz in speed so this phone was
actually not that bad it was actually
somewhat of a powerhouse mobile
computing device of course compared to
today's phones with 4 gigabytes of RAM
and 8 core processors in the
two-and-a-half gigahertz range you can
see that things have really come
way the IBM Simon today doesn't sound
like much but as you can imagine at the
time it was an absolutely revolutionary
concept so revolutionary that it would
take another 13 years until the
smartphone industry truly realized once
again that a screen that could change to
fit your application works better than
fixed buttons it's funny how things go
so hopefully that enlightened you
somewhat and that was just a fun little
bit of tech history if you want to see
more alternative stuff on many aspects
of technology and society don't forget
to subscribe thanks for watching guys
this has been - go go you're been
watching cold fusion and I'll catch you
again soon for the next video cheers
guys have a good one
cold fusion it's rethinking